so jetzt sieht haftbefehl so richtig vom
leder im fragen motto wenn ihr also
wissen wollte wer der beste rapper mit
knallharten texten und den besten beats
ist schaut dieses video und wie wichtig
die hessische soziale ader
gemixt mit frankfurter geldmacher thum
für den erfolg sind auch das erfahrt ihr
jetzt in diesem video abonnieren nicht
vergessen und bis am blattrand
abonnieren da oben
wir kommen zum finale
die meisten bürger und gemeinde fragen
und das waren heute okay die roten sind
wieder böse liebe bösen grünen den namen
los und so weiter und so fort schrieben
sie schlafen ist schon mein problem weg
ich merke dass meine probleme auf
das schöne was du
weisst du dich endlich eine frage ja
wenn ich jetzt wirklich sagen ich war
bei facebook löschen ja aber ich bin ja
gar nicht angemeldet
aber du hast eine fansite auf facebook
fanseiten zu machen die leute vom tag
läuft die machen meine leute als ich
habe drei oder
1080i
280.000 gefällt mir oder fans oder was
ja ja
ich weiß noch nicht mal wie viel 80.000
dollar gleich und 280.000 noch mal extra
schön naja es ist auch kein
nice nice und zwar noch mal auf meiner
seite wacker und ich weiß nicht
übernehme ich habe ja keine zeit und
office mit tourismus geld sehen
verschlüsse
okay ja da sind noch ein paar grünen ach
so ja ich bin vollauf mal ein bob marley
trip aber man hat auch noch so geil
interviews gemacht weil es ist ja wahr
zu haben obwohl sehr populär war auch
ein richtiger macher weil auch immer
nicht aufgemuckt hat zwar kein geld aber
dann sagen gras gezeigt übrigens beste
glas auf der
rastafari ob malerei war brach das dach
wo es früher
es ist nicht peinlich
was ist ein schwindel
ich bin weil ich
ja ich weiß ja lustig ja ich habe das
werden wir irgendwann die parade
sowie der überlegenheit
jahrgang ist ärgert mich denn ich möchte
nicht peinlich peinlich
peinlich warst du peinlichen alt da ich
sein es ist auf dem straßenstrich
ich bin nicht entspannt ich mach gilt
peinlich ist man dann wenn man zehn
jahren lebt und kein erfolg ich glaube
seit einem jahr und mit der flickr man
uns hier kann man nicht nächste frage
hier muss ja meine grüne ziehen ich
liebe gut
ich kläre es meine probleme und danach
kommen wir dann zum spaß so erst mal
wenn die feine gefechten da wird geld
gezählt so was
wann machst du endlich gute musik
ab dem zehnten februar mache ich auch
sehr gute musik auf den 10 februar könnt
ihr alle meine haltung kaufen kann aktiv
in den stores geht in den laden kauft
euch die special edition premium edition
limited edition schwanz indischen alles
edition gibt es mit t shirts mit als
faktisches alles dabei wie übernehmen
nächste frage
was die frage ist ja ich weiß ich weiß
ich weiß dabei war ganz gut ich bin ich
ganz gut hier hat man da so schlechtem
wetter solchen erfolg
ich muss mal dass ich muss mal umgekehrt
als schlechtwetter ist es einfach nur
hinter mir zumachen es aus ja es geht ja
gar nicht in die musik
wir sagen nur nach geld dann denken wir
heute mal das geld dann sagen sie man
automatisch gute musik dann kaufen damit
sie wieder
genau das ist
das würde also der marketing strategie
an erzählt einfach die ganze manchmal
folgen ich mal verliert das heißt
automatisch die leute denken die musik
zwar scheiße aber dafür noch so werden
also muss die musik gut sein also wenn
ich die musik nicht kauft wird damit ich
ein außenseiter warum wir so viel geld
weil sie haben den menschen ist kaufen
aber ich muss ja auch zu sein wieder
andere menschen sind muss aber haben wie
viele alben kaufen in den nächsten
lieder lang wahrscheinlich sehen kann so
was wie kommst du so gut an
er war der beste wert haben und
knallharten text haben die besten weg
den westen gut an und das beste team und
mich herum deswegen komme nicht so gut
an und weil ich bin ich bin ich verstehe
mich nicht
jetzt kommt
ich sage ganz ehrlich
kanada hat sich sehr sehr
mit dem mit dem viel rumreisen jetzt
letztlich hält auch geeignet zu lassen
ich war über einen gewissen in
deutschland und überall in jeder stadt
reden die anders die ausländer verstehst
in jeder stadt zeigen gibt so haben die
reifen sprach worte meine sprache
benutzt wörter wie es baulich benannt
wird anders wird als bei uns frankfurt
berlin köln düsseldorf überall will sein
andere wörter benutzt du hast du und ich
habe mir das angeeignet und überall hat
mich aufgesaugt so auch in russland
gewesen amerika aber dass amerikaner ja
später das war ja nach dem album aber
das wird es auch die nächsten flash ein
bisschen
aber du sagst es gibt schon also dass
die deutschen mit migrationshintergrund
in jeder stadt ein eigenes länger ja ja
egal ob türke rote fahne ja es ist immer
ist auch noch andere kultur also dass
kultur immer noch andere
lebensart meter an die stadt deutschland
sind richtig geil alter es ist nicht so
in deutschland ist zwar nicht in
russland aber in jeder stadt die stadt
ein anderes flavour deswegen haben sich
die rapper auch in jeder stadt ein
bisschen gleichermaßen weil sie den
gleichen fehler es kommt ist er hat nun
noch die straße geht das finde ich
richtig geiler ja du bist ja auch ein
bisschen frankfurter jungen mutter auf
die macher bei diesem mix ist mein
vorteil in dem fall wird dann so was du
immer so wie sie dieses thema und habe
auch wieder so was andere sagen dieses
richtige hesse was diese soziale ader
und auch das frankfurter gemixte dieses
macher gentner frankfurter theatermacher
und wenn du diese mission unmin ist also
kann das aufhalten und es hat nur offen
sein für alles was macht mich so
authentisch
wie meine vergangenheit also ja meine
vergangenheit machten sich meine
vergangenheit machen ständig
das war das fragen vielen dank